ユーチューバーたるもの何が大切かというともちろんカメラなんです多分ねやっぱり
打つかして見られたいんですよ
やっぱり映像なんで youtube 意見ご美しい映像を皆さんにお届けできるかと
いうことで僕も最初はねなんかすごい安っぽいビデオカメラから youtube
はじめてエラーレス一眼っていうねこの背景がボケる美しい映像に
緑で m の中一眼だったなあこの商品見せるとき自分の交尾ピントが合ってこの商品
が墓穴合うから謎とビデオカメラのほうがいいかなとビデオカメラにもって当然様に
まぁ結局やっぱり綺麗な映像が一番いいし自分も方かっこよく映るかなってことで今一
眼レフを使っているわけなんですけども今使ってるビデオカメラいいよさ82秒つで
結構まあそこそこ
綺麗に撮れていると思うんですけどもこれを使ってねもうたぶん1年ぐらいかな
どれに取れないだったけど
そろそろ変えようかなってさらなるステップアップを目指してちょっと
[音楽]
カメラを変えようと思いましたこちらカメラでこの大きさですよ
はい私ビデオそれを張ってきましたてが値段ガースー6万円です
コメント0
本当にごめ開封分気ができない普通に開けますねがぁあああああもうなんかって風
カイナーカメラ以外でも入ってますねあ止めてなんか色々買ったんですか
今回の壁の本当に慎重に使うといけないのでバッグを買いました
あーこっちが本体ですこのカメラ僕ずっと欲しいなと思ってたんですけどもすぐに何か
値段も値段だすれば買わねーなと思ったんですけどもうそのそもステップアップしても
いい時期なのかなと思いまして
買いましたこちら言いやす c 100マークっつー
みんなを張った新100ですよテトさんとかが勝ってるカメラをようやく私も手に入れ
たっていう話なんです
けど
なにこれ根津メンズカバーバッテリーチャージャー困難だ
どんなに2つ丸は考え保管と官は感がほとんどわかんないパッテリー
oc 音たこれがレンズですね誰かものが多いな悶絶これ影の日常的に使うかどうかは
また別なんですけども
ちょいしっかりしたビデオカメラを1台僕が欲しかったっていうわけで今回買わせて
いただきます
ああああああ
うわぁこれすげーなー
もういいなぁもうなんかじゃないなぁこんなに綺麗のグリップが持つが迂闊にビデオ
塗料なんで赤いボタンをポチッと押せば録画ができるという
voodoo
普通の
北はこんな感じになってしまいました
水ちょっとずれちゃったピョン逆にこっちから伝わらないであろうこの綺麗さ
どれだけはぐにゃん
ふーん山々版リーグ ba ba ba ba というわけでちょっとまずいか作れ
ちょっと怖い感じがするんですけどももうなんか鮮明だは戦目ですこれ60なのかな
60南欧系俺の好きな設定にしましたはい中継でメイン回路を切り替える気がします
その次からこれで取るのかなぁわからないですけど
が綺麗な映像が撮れるのでなどとって
みようと思いますどうぞ
[音楽]
me
dea
me あった
[音楽]